a New York man wrongfully locked up for
18 years finally had his conviction
vacated the Brooklyn dea's office says
that there was a mistake with the photo
lineup take a look at these two photos
the one on the left was the suspect in a
murder Sheldon Thomas the photo on the
right shows another man also named
Sheldon Thomas in 2004 police showed the
first photo to a witness as part of a
photo lineup she identified him as being
involved in a deadly Christmas Eve
shooting but the police went to the home
of the other Sheldon Thomas who lived in
the same Precinct they arrested him and
that same witness identified him as the
suspect despite him being completely
different from the photo she identified
Thomas was convicted of second-degree
murder and attempted murder and was
sentenced to 25 years in prison Thomas
was released though on Thursday having
spent more than half of his life Behind
Bars
Brian you practiced in Brooklyn Supreme
Court what do you think about this yeah
I'm not surprised in any way shape or
form I'm glad that Eric Gonzalez a D.A
in Brooklyn now has this review unit
where they're looking at these cases but
I think the real heroes here are the
Appellate group that
um actually the attorney who led it was
Bill casting with a K he spent 14 years
fighting for Mr Thompson to get the case
here and thankfully in front of the
Chief Justice in the Supreme Court in
Brooklyn judge demick he actually got it
dismissed but the fight here is from the
defense attorneys not the prosecutors
Terry made me think you know this
there's other people who are locked up
for crimes they didn't commit had in
groups like the Innocence Project
determine which cases did it take on you
know it's difficult there are so many of
these types of cases out there what the
Innocence Project does is they look at
thousands of applications you must be in
the United States for one thing and you
have to have DNA you have to have
physical evidence that shows you we're
not guilty it's interesting they don't
take self-defense cases they don't take
DWI cases so there's certain types of
cases that they will not take the main
thing is if they can't take it they have
a network of 71 organizations that will
help you so for instance in New York New
York law school has an organization that
will help you if you need to fight your
case that's my alma mater always doing
good work well there was a tense back
and forth Friday between the man
defending the alleged ice cream man
murderer and a witness who's trying to
pin a Revenge plot on his client Michael
keatley was an ice cream truck driver
more than a decade ago when he was
robbed of twelve dollars he was actually
shot in the process which left him
disabled now prosecutors allege that he
wanted revenge against the thieves and
plotted to kill them on Thanksgiving Day
of 2010 police say keatley gunned down
multiple people at a home killing two of
them but they say he targeted the wrong
group keatley's defense claims that he
was misidentified as the suspect there
was a previous trial it ended in a hung
jury and then on Friday a man who worked
with keatley in the ice cream truck
after he was robbed testified that he
offered heard keatley talk about his
need for Revenge the defense brought up
though a deposition of David Beckwith
that he gave previously that seems to
contradict what he's saying now
this was a question
I guess what is your pla your particular
plans what is your particular plans Mike
was going to go up there and go boo and
you would come up behind them and grab
them or kidnap people
did you have any specific plans
your answer yeah to act like police
officers
that was you're saying my plan is mine
it wasn't my plan what did you say in a
sworn deposition that it was your plan
it was it was his plan to do all this
didn't you say in a deposition that it
was his plan my your I I I'm not an
English professor
your plan right you're saying me I'm the
one that devised all this this is
I didn't devise anything
and to finish off today's show we're
putting the spotlight back on Brian
coburger this is the man charged the
murders of the Idaho four this week his
defense team is allowed to add one more
seat to that defense table coburger is
represented by Ann Taylor this is the
chief of the Kootenai County Public
Defender's Office she's tasked with
helping her client Escape murder charges
related to the stabbing deaths of four
Idaho college students in November if
convicted co-berger could face a life
sentence or the death penalty now
there's no confirmation that prosecutors
are actually going to seek the death
penalty but coburger's defense team
wants to be prepared and last week
Taylor filed a motion requesting a death
qualified defense attorney to join their
team the judge approved that motion
letting coburger's defense be an
official Party of Three so Terry what
factors do the prosecution consider when
they decide whether to seek the death
penalty or not well we're in the state
of Idaho and there actually are 11
factors that they have to consider these
are the aggravating factors obviously
the mitigating factors can outweigh
those but here I don't think that's
going to happen they just need one some
of them include multiple murders the
fact that they're especially heinous
atrocious and cruel and he can be a
threat to society he has a disregard for
life all of those those are four right
there I think will apply in this case
and I think that is why the prosecution
is considering it they don't have to
signal right now what they're going to
do but at some point before the trial
they will signal and they will seek that
death penalty I believe in this case so
well Brian the co-burger motion to
appoint another death penalty attorney
it's barely two pages it has a lot of
statutes constitutions can you make
heads or tails of it yeah so let's go
for the easier ways first Fifth and 14th
Amendment due process in Federal and
State Court sixth amendment my third
favorite one right to Council in eighth
against cruel unusual punishment but the
standards here that are Statewide they
do talk about the standards for
qualification for the defense attorney
making sure that they are good enough to
be able to do a death penalty case you
don't want someone who has been doing
misdemeanors for the last six years to
step up to a death penalty case and the
other one the rule is 61.000 whatever
whatever the administration of indigent
defense does highlight a very key issue
here that you can't just have one death
qualified attorney you actually need to
have two I would say to someone who's
done felonies homicides violent crimes
misdemeanors misdemeanors after a couple
years of practicing maybe it can be just
you but felonies and more serious crimes
you need to have I would say at least
two highly qualified attorneys to help
do that case that's why I see one person
do openings another person often do
closing arguments yeah while he's
building the team Terry Brian you're
both great I want to thank you both I
want to thank Brian's Newfound mustache
this has been a terrific show and
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here on Long crime daily we're gonna see
you next time as we discuss Justice
thank you
[Music]
foreign